don't be average most businesses fail
eighty percent plus of new businesses
will fail will shut down and it's
because they were average you want to
have success you need to be different
you need to stand out you need to have a
secret sauce something different and a
lot of times that's you just pouring
more of yourself and your passions into
the business to make it special don't be
average I just finished a cruise with
carnival and I went to nine different
cities / 10 days and on the last day I'm
sitting around we're sitting at the
table having our last dinner and we
tried to think what was the best food
that we had on the ship and none of us
to come up with what was the best food
nothing was terrible you know we didn't
get food poisoning nobody died but
nothing was great nothing was memorable
so we thought okay forget about the food
what about the cruise ship was was
exciting or memorable and again nothing
came to mind it was just average nothing
to complain about sometimes the high
prices of things the rip off but in
general is just an average cruise ship
this is a problem this is a problem for
Carnival this is a problem for all the
cruise lines and it's probably a problem
for your business because I have no
reason to tell anybody about the cruise
ship that I was on there was nothing
special about there's nothing that's
going to get me to talk about carnival
because it was just average it was okay
does okay make me want to come back and
buy more it's okay make me want to tell
my friends about it it's okay make me
want to tweet about it and take pictures
and post on facebook and tell everybody
I'll the world no okay is average an
average is not good enough average is
not special average does not get you
anywhere even thinking beyond we thought
about all the stores that we visited all
the entrepreneurs that we met with over
the 10
days and nobody really stood out as
having anything exceptional the best was
a store in Florence it was a leather
goods store he sold purses and jackets
of great Florentine leather and he
didn't have anything that we liked the
style wasn't great it just wasn't for us
but he was a great person I came into
the store he talked to me he told me
what was going on in the city we had
some great conversation as I left he
blew air kisses with both of his hands
and said kisses to you enjoy your
vacation and I didn't even buy anything
from this guy he was the most memorable
business that I met on my whole trip
he's the only one I'm going to think
about this is a huge problem and a huge
opportunity for you because most
businesses are average that's the
definition of average most businesses
are average and a polo means your
business's average but it also means
your competitors are average and it
means is a huge opportunity for you to
stand up to stand out to be different to
be special to get noticed because people
want to talk about you give them a
reason I was searching for something
different to talk about for this video
what I'm going to talk about for a radio
show what am I going to talk about I was
thinking and I couldn't find anything
except that one store in Florence or it
didn't even buy from stand out find
something that is unique about you pour
yourself into your business so that
people will get excited about what you
do here the steps that you need to take
okay number one figure out what it is
that you stand for don't look at every
other store every other company your
industry what makes you you what do you
personally believe in do you believe in
family
do you believe in service do you believe
in an entrepreneurship what is it what
do you believe in and make your whole
business about that and it doesn't even
matter what you sell because now you're
talking about values and marketing is
all about values a couple weeks ago I
did a video about this florist who want
to start a flower shop and flower shops
are competitive right it's hard to make
money as a flower shop there's tons of
flower shops out there how are you going
to stand out and he was all about calm
flowers mint com to him when he sat with
flowers they calmed him down hey people
live a stressful life they need calm now
everything in his store should be about
calm the flower should become the
environment should become the employees
should be calm everything is trying to
create this calm and tranquil
environment now you're not a flower
store now you're different than
everybody else because you stand for
something you have values you want
people to come who will be calm who are
searching for calm in their lives now
you become a destination shop who people
will come and they'll spend more money
with you and you'll find ideal clients
because the people coming believe the
same thing as you they're not just
coming from flowers anymore they're
coming to seek out calmness whatever the
word is for you whatever the belief that
you have that's your first step you have
to figure that out and put into
everything that you do with your
business don't be average when you pour
yourself into your business you'll make
more money you'll have more fun you have
a lot more success and you'll have a
much greater impact on your family and
on your community I hope you do
something today to make your business
different and stop being average
belief thank you everybody for watching
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes you want to do
more and i'd love to hear what you have
to think if you'll only comment
underneath tell me what your business
problems are I'll do a beauty response I
love seeing your comments come in thank
you so much I'll see you soon